she's sleeping
at least i think she is her eyes are
closed and she's not shaking anymore
i would have already killed her by now
if i didn't feel so bad for her
how's she feeling use your imagination
that place sucked every last drop of
humanity from her
it's not enough she already gave up
everything she had
i just kept taking more and more she's
in some
kind of trance like she's folded into
herself
no reaction to her surroundings
whatsoever
i really really didn't want to poke
around in her head
i did it for you i just want you to know
that
i need to talk to her listen i know
you've got some serious questions that
she's got the answers to
i mean if i were you i'd want to know
too but it's just not gonna happen
she's completely out of it you've gotta
be [ __ ] kidding me
you're mad at her why
when you asked me to scour her
behavioral chip i was just about
done dealing with your [ __ ] judy i
didn't have any
no it's okay so i don't get why
you'll find out in a sec i'll show you
the virtue i found
guessing you saw them already yeah i had
to wrestle to make sense of the whole
thing
but i don't want to say anything and
taint your perspective you should go in
with fresh eyes
how many bds did you manage to rip two
only one of them's intact understandable
though
the rest well they're in the same
shape as that okay right now show me
give me a sec while i set the parameters
guess we'll find out if our doll really
did lose her tune
come on pee
i'll be the first to admit this does not
look good
um
well now look at you
hey how you feeling
you need anything i'm not here to nag
just talk
i know it's a bad time but i gotta ask
you got any idea how to remove the
biochip
or know anyone else who might
listen evelyn i really need your help
it's important if i don't do anything
and do it soon
i'll die
you're right this is a complete waste of
time
hey you need anything
i'm not here you're right this is a
complete waste of time
have a seat
all right roll it data was in pretty
rough shape
not all that editable huh
glad you managed to salvage them in the
first place
needs a second to load
quality is lousy but i did what i could
what am i looking out for every single
piece of tech i see
security we need a layout of the whole
room
we will get everything else we need from
the virtue
what about his messages only if you can
do it and be
puffy it's most important that he
suspect nothing
try to be your usual relaxed self
and if he starts talking about the bio
chip himself
should i
where you hear this that is not of
interest to you
you spin the virtue you come back here
we give you the eddies
that is your one job the rest
is none of your concern understand
what am i looking at take a look around
think i recognize these
what are they weave markings you
familiar with them
not enough to know what they actually
mean
heard of who might use them though who
could
i wouldn't know where to start
can't see your face
under normal circumstances that kind of
encryption's easy to crack
but not this time whoever she is she's
got
serious net running skills
that where someone's working it for her
[Music]
try to be your usual relaxed self
might not be important maybe
all of them are from pacifica now's down
our search at least
what now looks like
i'm going on a field trip to pacifica
all right i think we got everything
[Music]
what do you think
now we know what happened to clouds
they're the ones who tried to flatline
her
launched a nuke at her chip so it was
punishment for getting played by her
she knew more than they thought she knew
couldn't let that go
so that's who she was running from
the woman who hired evelyn any idea who
we're up against
your guest is as good as mine sorry v
it looks like evelyn never told us the
whole truth
you're telling me if i'd known what
she'd gotten herself into
i'm so mad at her her only job was to
record a virtue
it's pretty damn amazing she managed to
organize a full-blown heist
and swipe the biochip from under her
boss's noses
so that's where you came in she hired
you
and brought this all on herself
on youtube there's one more recording
want to see it sure why not
nothing can surprise me at this point
i don't know haitian creole it is the
voodoo boys
didn't i wait let me see if i've got an
auto translator
meantime you try to tune into the
phone's frequency
[Music]
got it give it a second
why evelyn buried this recording deep
cut another name
something like silver hat
we have to know what they're saying it
could be important
fine just found the auto translate
package
should get along fine with your system
i'll install it now
foreign
okay judy we're good all right
disconnecting
i don't get it what's this have to do
with johnny silverhand
he died like forever ago
me you got any idea
a biochip we stole it's uh
it's got silverhand's engram burned onto
it
engram digitized psyche
personality construct
[Music]
can you give me a minute i need to go
over some stuff
in my head um of course
know who they are who the woman is any
idea how we find them
[ __ ] fee i've been dead the last half
century
sorry if i'm unable to hand you all the
answers on a chrome [ __ ] platter when
you snap your fingers
these people what could they want from
alt how the hell
should i know got no notion whatsoever
one way or another everything leads back
to that network
finding hers our biggest priority if she
knows as much as i think she knows about
the chip
she can help us out i thought you said
nothing could help us
nah just find us that juju wirehead okay
wait you got any idea how to get in
touch with the voodoo boys
i'll ask around make a few calls let me
put it this way
the voodoo boys wouldn't trust a cat if
it walked onto their turf
but someone's gotta know way in well
good luck
i hope you won't need it
what's up with you see you around judy
right um thanks
vee
you